in this video you're going to learn how
to work with the difference quotient and
the derivative and we'll go through five
different types of examples involving
the difference quotient and the
derivatives so let's dive in this is
designed to be a complete guide for you
let's first talk about what exactly is
the difference quotient now you remember
from Algebra 1 how to find the slope of
a line and we use this formula Y2 minus
y1 over X2 minus X1 it's the change in y
over the change in X which is oftentimes
referred to in word problems as the rate
of change and so if you're looking at a
function say for example this is your
graph and you take a look at two points
that lie on that graph let's just call
this first point here
X or going x to the right and when you
go up to that point the y coordinate
since you're putting X into your
function that y value is going to be f
of x so this point here is X comma f of
x and then if you go a little further
distance here to the right let's just
call that distance H so what you're
doing is you're going X Plus H to get to
this point here and when you go up to
this point on the graph when you put
that into your function
the Y value is going to be f of x plus h
and so now what we're going to do is
we're going to look at the average rate
of change between these two points on
this function and when you think about
the average rate of change you're
thinking about what is the slope
of this secant line and remember secant
from geometry it cuts across the graph
at two points so you can see it's
intersecting this graph here at two
points and so we're going to use this
slope formula by saying Y2 minus y1 so
that's going to be f of x plus h minus f
of x
all divided by X2 minus X1 so that's
going to be X Plus H minus X
and notice that these two x values they
cancel out because one's positive and
one's negative and so you can see what
we're getting here
f of x plus h minus f of x all over H
this is what we call your difference
quotient difference means like
subtraction quotient see this fraction
bar means like Division and so all
together we call it the difference
quotient but what it really represents
is the average rate of change or the
slope of this secant line
now where does the derivative come in
well the derivative comes in when you
take the limit as H approaches 0 of this
difference quotient what does that mean
as H approaches zero it means as this
distance here between these two points
gets smaller and smaller this point here
gets closer and closer
to this point until when H approaches
zero it's getting closer and closer
until the two points are actually like
right on top of one another they like
coincide
and so what happens here is instead of
getting the secant line because these
two points are right on top of one
another you're actually getting the
slope of the tangent line
to the function
and remember from geometry tangent is
where the line just barely touches the
graph at one point and so we're finding
that slope of that tangent line at that
particular point and we call this F
Prime of X that's the derivative of the
function okay and this is the notation
for it so it's really using the
different quotient but then taking it a
step further as that uh limit of H
approaches zero now you can use this
derivative to find a formula for the
slope of the tangent line at any point
along the curve here you can see the
slope here is a little bit steeper but
it becomes less steep less steep here it
actually starts to turn negative right
so this gives us a formula for the slope
at any point and this formula here F
Prime of a you can see all I'm really
doing is I'm replacing the x value with
a particular a value or I should say x
coordinate of our point on our graph to
find the slope of the tangent line at a
particular point so we're going to use
these formulas in the five examples
let's dive into those five examples Now
find the slope of f of x equals x
squared minus 2x at the point 2 comma
zero
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use our
difference quotient but we're going to
find the slope at a particular point so
let's use this form right here so we're
going to say
F Prime of 2
is equal to the Limit as H approaches 0
of f of 2 plus h minus F of 2
all divided by H all I did is I put the
x coordinate of our point in for a
now we're going to simplify this
difference quotient so whatever's in the
parentheses see this 2 plus h whatever
is in the parenthesis goes in for X on
the right side of the equation so it's
just like a substitution so what you
have here is you have 2 plus h
squared minus 2 times 2 plus h notice I
put the two plus age in for both X's
minus F of 2. now I'm going to put this
in parentheses F of 2 now I'm going to
replace x with 2. so this is going to be
2 squared minus 2 times 2.
all divided by
H and it's the limit as H approaches
zero so now we just have to do a little
bit of arithmetic and simplify 2 plus h
squared remember is really like 2 plus h
times another 2 plus h so let's just
write that over here on the side 2 plus
h squared means 2 plus h twice and you
can distribute or foil however you like
to think about that and so that's going
to come out to 4
plus 2H plus another 2H is 4H
plus h times H is H squared
a lot of times students make a mistake
they just say 2 squared plus h squared
but that's not right you have to foil it
out okay minus let's distribute this 2
here so this is going to be minus 4
minus 2H I'm treating this like a
negative 2 Distributing
and over here we have minus 2 squared is
4 minus 2 times 2 is 4 that's 0 so this
is just minus zero all divided by h
okay now let's do a little bit more
simplifying here we've got zero of
course is nothing 4 minus four that's
just zero and we have four h minus two H
is 2H
plus h squared
all divided by H now what you can do is
you can factor out an H out of the
numerator so that's going to be 2 plus h
all divided by H and you can see that
these H as they cancel numerator and
denominator remember multiplication and
division are are inverses and so now
we're just left with let me write it
over here
2 plus h but remember it's the limit
as H approaches zero so it's the limit
as H approaches zero of this quantity so
now at this last step here we can put 0
in place of h two plus zero is just
going to be 2 and so what that tells us
is that
the slope of the uh
tangent line okay at the point 2 0 is
going to be 2. let's just take a quick
look at what this graph looks like for a
moment x squared minus 2x is going to
have zeros at zero
and at two okay so these are your
x-intercepts we've got an axis of
symmetry here at one if we put one and
we get 1 minus 2 is negative one so you
can see our this is like a parabola that
looks something like this right but at
this point two comma 0 which is right
here the slope of that graph which is
really like the slope of the tangent
line at that point it's going to have a
slope of 2.
let's take a look at another example
find a formula for the slope of f of x
equals 3 minus x squared
and number three find the equation of
the tangent line at the point one comma
two so these questions kind of go
together here now for number two when we
find a formula we're just finding like a
generic formula for the slope of the
graph at any point along the graph and
if the graph isn't a straight line that
slope is going to change depending on
where you are on the graph right so what
we can do here is we can use this
formula here
okay our derivative to find that formula
for the slope of the graph at any point
doesn't matter this is just for a
particular point this could be any point
so let's start off by saying F Prime of
X is equal to the Limit
as H approaches 0 of f of x plus h minus
f of x all divided by H now remember the
way we do this is we take whatever's in
the parentheses which is this quantity X
plus h
and whatever's in the parenthesis that's
going to go in for X on the right side
of the equation so let's go ahead and do
that substitution so we have 3 minus
X Plus H squared
minus f of x now f of x represents this
entire function so I'm going to put it
in parentheses to treat it like a group
sometimes people forget to
treat it as a group and they make a
little calculation error and then this
is all divided by H now this is the
limit
as H approaches zero so we have a little
bit of arithmetic to take to do here we
have to expand this out X Plus H times X
Plus H which comes out to x squared plus
2 h x plus h squared
all I did is I did X Plus H times
another X plus h
and then over here I'm going to
distribute the negative so that's going
to give us negative 3 plus x squared
all divided by H okay now what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to distribute
this negative so when I distribute this
negative this is actually going to
become negative x squared minus 2hx
minus H squared minus 3
plus x squared all divided by H so we
should have some cancellation here let's
see what cancels we've got a negative x
squared and a positive x squared we have
a positive 3 and a negative 3. and so
what we're left with is negative
2 h x minus H squared all divided by h
now you can see we can factor out an H
so let's go ahead and do that up here so
we'll say h
is a negative 2
X
minus h
all divided by h
and you can see that the H is cancel
numerator and denominator but remember
this is the limit as H approaches zero
so what we can do now is we can put 0 in
place of H so that's just going to give
us negative 2X and this is our
derivative so F Prime of X is equal to
negative 2x so that's a formula for the
slope
of the graph at any point along the
curve now let's take a look for a moment
before we do number three what exactly
does this graph look like well
we can see that it's a parabola that's
opening down that's so the negative x
squared tells us and the 3 is Shifting
the graph up three so the graph is going
to look something like this
where it's opening down
and it's going to cross the x-axis at
plus or minus square root of 3 which is
about 1.7 negative 1.7 so that's
basically what our graph looks like and
what this represents is a formula for
the slope anywhere along the graph so if
I was over here at 0 and I put 0 in here
negative 2 times 0 is 0. you can see the
slope of our graph is a horizontal line
or has a slope of zero but if I was to
put in say for example like a negative 2
that's going to be right here you can
see it's going to be negative 2 times
negative 2 is 4 it's going to be a
positive slope so depending on where
you're on the graph
the slope of the graph and the slope of
the tangent line are going to be
different
but for question number three it says
find the equation
of the tangent line at the point one
comma two so one comma 2 is right here
if we take the
x coordinate 1 and put it in for X here
this is f Prime of 1.
you can see that comes out to negative
2. so what that means is this at this
point has a slope of negative 2.
we know the equation of a line is y
minus y1 equals m times x minus X1 this
is our point slope form so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to put 1 in for
X1 2 in for y1 and we know that our
slope
is negative two so we have y minus 2 is
equal to negative two times x minus 1.
now let's simplify this a little bit
let's distribute the negative two
that's going to give us negative two X
plus two
and if we add 2 to both sides that gives
us negative 2x plus 4
and now if we graph this
you can see that this graph
is going to look something like this
that's the graph of our tangent line it
has a slope of negative two a y
intercept of four
and you got it let's take a look at
another example okay for example number
four it says use the derivative to find
any turning points of this function f of
x equals X cubed minus 12x
so what does that mean turning points
well that's where the graph bends it's
where it has a maximum point or a
minimum point so if we were to graph
this just drawing kind of like a rough
sketch we could factor out an X and that
would give us let's see x squared minus
12.
okay and we can Factor this a little bit
further by saying X Plus square root of
12 and x minus square root of 12. so if
we set these factors equal to zero we
can see that our zeros or our
x-intercepts are going to be at 0.
negative root 12 and positive root 12.
now square root of 12 is about somewhere
in between 3 and 4 because 3 squared is
9 4 squared is 16. so that means it's
going to cross the x-axis somewhere
around here roughly and somewhere around
here roughly we know that the leading
coefficient is positive we know it's
going up to the right it's an odd degree
so we know it's going down to the left
and so this graph is going to look
something like
this but the question that we're
interested in now is how do we find
exactly where the graph bends like how
do I know this graph doesn't go way up
here and then like way down here or how
do I know the graph just doesn't go up
just a little bit and then kind of turns
around so we're trying to find the exact
location of these quote unquote turning
points these extrema or these maximums
and minimas
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make use of our derivative again
to find a slope of our tangent line and
we're looking for the slope of the
tangent line is equal to zero or
horizontal because when it bends that's
where the graph has a horizontal or a
zero slope so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to say f Prime of X our
derivative is equal to the Limit as H
approaches zero
of f of x plus h minus f of x
all divided by H now remember the way
that this works is whatever is in
parentheses that goes in for X on the
right side of the equation so that's
going to come out to X plus h
cubed
minus 12 times X plus h
minus f of x f of x is this whole
function so I'm going to put it in
parentheses so we treat it like a group
all divided by
H okay now we've got a little bit of
work ahead of us because X Plus H cubed
is like X Plus H times X Plus H times X
Plus H you can also use the binomial
expansion theorem to help you expand
this but if you've forgotten that
let's just go ahead and do X Plus H
times X Plus H times X plus h x plus h
squared we've done this in previous
examples today already that's this
and then if we multiply by another X
Plus H what do we get we get X cubed
we get 2 h x squared plus h squared x
now I'm going to distribute the x that
gives us
h x squared plus 2 H squared x
plus h cubed and if we combine like
terms let's see what do we have here we
have X cubed
Plus
2hx squared plus 1hx squared is 3 h x
squared
plus h squared X plus two H squared x is
3 H squared X Plus H cubed
okay
minus 12x minus 12 h
okay minus X cubed plus 12x Distributing
that negative into the parentheses
all divided by h
okay and let's see we should have some
cancellation the X cubed and the
negative X cubed cancels the negative
12x and the positive 12x cancels and
then what we can do is we can divide all
these terms in the numerator by H so
like this is going to cancel out this H
that's going to give us 3x squared
that's going to cancel out one of these
H's which is going to give us 3hx that's
going to cancel out one of these H's
which is H squared and it's going to
cancel out this H here which is going to
leave us with negative 12. now remember
it's the limit as H approaches zero so
if I put 0 in for H
all the terms that have an H in it
because you're putting in a zero and
zero times anything is zero these terms
are going to go to zero and so we're
left with three x squared minus 12.
is our derivative now remember our
derivative
is a formula for the slope of the graph
or the slope of the tangent line at any
point along that graph
but because we're looking at for where
the tangent line is horizontal or zero
we're going to set the derivative equal
to zero so we're going to say 0 is equal
to 3x squared minus 12.
we're going to add 12 to both sides
we're going to divide both sides by 3
so 4 is equal to x squared and we're
going to take the square root of both
sides but remember when you take the
square root of both sides how many
answers do you get 2 right plus or minus
so plus or minus 2.
so now what this tells us is that when X
is equal to negative 2 we get a turning
point and positive 2. but how do we find
the y coordinate of that point where it
bends well we have to go back to the
original equation so I'm going to put 2
in for X so that's going to be F of 2 is
equal to 2 cubed minus 12 times 2 and f
of negative 2 which is negative 2 cubed
minus 12 times negative 2. so let's see
this comes out to 8 minus 24 which is
negative 16. so that means this is the
point
two comma negative 16 I should have
probably drawn a little bit bigger and
then over here this would be uh negative
eight
plus 24 which is positive 16. so at
negative 2 you're up here at positive
16.
and you got it so those are the
locations of the turning points let's
take a look at another example okay if
you like the way that I explain things
and you'd like to support the channel
consider joining as a channel member so
for a few dollars a month you can help
support the videos that I'm putting up
here on my Myers math tutoring YouTube
channel and I see all the supporters all
the names and the YouTube handles that
come through and I really appreciate
that but let's take a look at this last
example together find an equation of the
line that's tangent to this function
here
and it's parallel to this line so
sometimes when you're doing these
problems it's good to draw a sketch just
to get a feel for what exactly is this
talking about or referring to
if we graph this graph f of x equals 1
over X plus three you can see the
denominator cannot be zero right you
can't divide by zero that's undefined so
at negative 3
we're going to have a
vertical asymptote and if we plot some
you're also going to have a horizontal
asymptote
right here on the x-axis
and you can plot some various points
like for example if I put in a zero
that's going to be all one-third and
let's say we put in a negative 2 that's
going to be here at 1. and so this graph
basically it looks something like
this roughly and if we do another Branch
over here see if we put in a negative 4
that would be like a negative one
so this Branch kind of looks something
like like this
okay so you're with me so far so that's
this original function now this line
here X plus 9y equals 0. let's see if we
can rewrite this so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to uh
get the Y by itself
so let's go ahead and subtract X from
both sides
so we have 9y is equal to Negative X and
if we divide both sides by 9 you can see
that Y is equal to negative 1 9 x so
that means that this has a slope of
let's see it has a y intercept of zero
so our B value is 0 goes right through
the origin and has a slope of negative 1
9. so right one
down I'm sorry down one and right nine
so two three four five six seven eight
nine so somewhere right about here so
basically this
line
looks something like like that roughly
Okay negative 1 9 slope so we're trying
to figure out where along this original
graph would the tangent line be parallel
to this line right here okay you can see
it it's not going to be here because
it's going to
Cross or intersect that line so it has
to be somewhere along the curve parallel
to that line now remember the derivative
is a formula for the slope of the
tangent line anywhere along that
original graph
and what we're going to do is we're
going to set that derivative equal to
the slope of this line negative 1 9 to
help us to find those points so let's go
ahead and find our derivative so we're
going to say f Prime of X is equal to
the Limit as H approaches zero
of f of x plus h minus f of x all
divided by H right so that's the form
we've been using throughout this
lesson and so now what we have here is
the limit as H approaches zero now X
plus h
whatever's in parentheses is going to go
in for X on the right so this is equal
to 1 over X plus h
plus 3 minus f of x f of x is this whole
function here
1 over X plus 3 all divided by H now if
you try to put in 0 for H right now what
you would end up getting is
1 over X plus 3 minus one over X plus 3
which is 0 divided by zero which is
indeterminate so you can't have zero
divided by zero it's indeterminate we
have to rewrite this somehow and because
this is a complex fraction you have
fractions within a larger fraction we
need to simplify this complex fraction
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
get a common denominator here
this one I'm going to multiply the
numerator and denominator by X plus h
plus 3
because that's this denominator here and
this one I'm going to multiply by
X plus 3
to the numerator denominator now we have
a common denominator so we can combine
them into one fraction so it's going to
be X plus 3 times 1 is X Plus 3.
minus
X plus h plus 3 all over the common
denominator which is X plus 3 times X
plus h plus 3
all divided by H now let's see what we
have here we've got x minus X that's
zero and this is going to be a negative
H here let's write it above it so
negative x minus H minus 3 I just
distribute the negative and so the X's
cancel the negative 3 and the 3 cancel
and we have a negative H so we have a
negative H in the numerator now
divided by X plus 3 times X plus h plus
3 all divided by H now this H is
actually like H over 1 right because
anything divided by 1 is itself but when
we divide by a fraction remember how
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
so it's like multiplying by 1 over H
these H's are going to cancel leaving us
with a negative 1 in the numerator
so what we have here let me write it
over here is f Prime of X is equal to
the Limit as H approaches zero of
negative 1
over X plus 3
times X plus h plus 3.
okay now we can put 0 in for H that's
going to be X plus 3 times another X
plus 3 which X plus 3 times X plus 3 is
X plus 3 squared the quantity squared
like this and that's our
derivative but our derivative is just a
formula for the slope of the tangent
line we want to know where the tangent
line is parallel to this line which
means it has to have the same slope of
negative 1 9. so let's go ahead and
replace this with negative 1 9.
and we're going to solve this
equation here so let's go ahead and
cross multiply so we've got negative 1
times X plus 3 squared
is equal to 9 times negative 1 which is
negative 9. if we multiply both sides by
negative 1 we get X plus 3 squared which
is x squared plus 6X plus 9 is equal to
9.
because we multiplied both sides by
negative 1 and I just fold out the X
plus 3 squared and if I subtract 9 from
both sides we get x squared plus 6X is
equal to 0.
and if I factor out an X I get x times X
plus 6 equals zero and if I set both
factors equal to zero you can see that X
is equal to 0 and x is equal to negative
6.
now what does that mean well if I put 0
into my original
equation this is going to be the point
zero comma one-third
which is going to be right here and
that means at this point here you're
going to
have a tangent line that has a slope of
negative 1 9 so it's going to be
parallel to that
original line we drew and at negative 6
negative 6 plus 3 is negative 3 so
that's going to be 1 over negative 3
which is negative one-third so at
negative six one two three four five six
negative one-third right here
the slope of the tangent line
is also going to be
parallel to that line Y equals negative
1 9 x so to answer the question about
finding the equation of the line that's
tangent to this graph and parallel to
this line we've got the
points on our original graph and we know
that our slope is going to be negative 1
9 for both of these
so let's go ahead and write the
equations now this one we know the Y
intercept is one-third and we know the
slope is negative 1 9 so we can go right
into the form of our equation y equals
negative 1 9 X Plus one-third okay so
that's this line right here and then
this line here let's use the point-slope
form we'll say y minus y1
is equal to the slope negative 1 9 times
x minus X1
okay when you subtract it's like adding
the opposite
and so if I distribute the negative 1 9
now let's see we get negative 1 9 x
minus 6 9 which is a negative two-thirds
and if I subtract 1 3 to get y by itself
that's going to be Y is equal to
negative 1 9 x minus three thirds which
is a negative one
so now you've got the equations of your
two lines
and you got it great job if you're able
to follow all the examples in this video
if you want some more practice I'll put
a video right there where I talk more
about derivatives and difference
quotients and you can get some more
practice in that video I'll see you over
there